ça fait des années que les conservateurs
dépeignent la taxe carbone comme la pire
forme d'imposition qui soit ils ont une
ultime chance de plaider leur cause
cette semaine en cour suprême le défi
ici c'est que l'environnement est un
champ de compétences partagées entre
ottawa et les provinces 1867 au moment
de la répartition des pouvoirs
la question des changements climatiques
n'étaient évidemment pas une
préoccupation des pères de la
confédération
les neuf juges de la cour suprême
doivent déterminer si le gouvernement
fédéral a le droit d'imposer une taxe
sur le carbone aux provinces
ici en faisant ça ottawa s'immisce dans
leurs pouvoirs exclusifs
si ce que prétendent les avocats la
saskatchewan de l'ontario et de
l'alberta
les trois provinces craignent que le
gouvernement fédéral s'il obtient gain
de cause puisse ensuite réglementer tout
ce qui touche au gaz à effet de serre
ils vont vous dire combien de fois vous
pouvez conduire votre voiture plaide
l'avocat de l'ontario même si le québec
est d'accord avec ottawa sur l'idée
taxer la pollution
il a choisi d'appuyer les trois
provinces devant la cour parce qu'il
craint l'ingérence du gouvernement
fédéral dans les dossiers
environnementaux et on est des juifs
présents au contraire ottawa répond que
la loi y cible et qu'elle vise seulement
la tarification du carbone et que la
pollution nécessite une réponse
pancanadienne cohérente qui vient dans
tous les régions il n'y a pas les
frontières avec le après deux jours
d'audience la cour suprême devrait
trancher plus tard cet automne
et c'est une décision majeure pour le
gouvernement trudeau parce que la
tarification sur le carbone c'est
vraiment la pierre d'assise de son plan
vert si laurence partie radio canada
ottawa